excited to have some matches BAM
[Music]
this sort of looks like a breakfast
burger okay it's basic burgers pretty
standard in McDonald's I feel like this
is a burger that I maybe keep in my
pocket and save it for later
Bacon's a bit different this is not
bacon this is ham nothing's like
American bacon I mean you want the thin
slices you know the fix good but it's
like Canadian style I just can't get
around all right I don't think this is a
bacon it's a nice fancy bun my god and
everything bagel it's pretty big brother
there seems to be a lot of ketchup
losing a painting of ketchup on here hmm
that's pretty good to meet the bun ratio
on this it is on point there's actually
a lot going on here the sauce was very
surprising tasting kind of just like
spurted out the mighty Angus Moore I'm
barbecuing and hearty and like nothing
they would have in the u.s. sort tastes
like a cheese steak the condiments and
onions are give me a little bit of a
meatloaf vibe this is the meal you want
at 3:00 a.m. when all the bars closed
definitely not what I remember from
being six years old and getting a Big
Mac
[Music]
it looks kind of like a Big Mac but a
lot smaller lots of toppings it's pretty
good the amount of vegetables on this is
commendable almost like your dollar menu
Americans are the psycho quarter-pounder
with now so Big Mac had a little cousin
this will be it maybe it was just a
dream but I feel at one time they had
frozen coke in the u.s. here we go whoa
chunky I doesn't taste like the coke I'm
used to frozen coke definitely is better
than normal coke cuz then you didn't
have to wait out the ice you don't have
to worry about it watering down your
drink I wish they had frozen coke in the
US cos and I could sneak it into the
movie
I'm actually from the southwest when you
hand a Texan a Southwest burger
it better be legitimate stacking it nice
and high with a poof topic when the hell
- McDonald's get so fancy no it's got
something like Big Mac sauce what is
that I was like Taco Bell specifically a
collaboration between McDonald's and
talk about what nacho chips is that a
corn chip the chips is at a really weird
texture like it's almost dangerous I
mean I think the Southwest is almost
like this Cajun spicy like herbs that go
on it I'm this good flavor don't get me
wrong it's a good burger but I don't
think has anything to do with the
Southwest this one's I like the song
machan is just a cruel man